[Music]  Orlando Bloom gushes over being a dead  I'm very lucky man  et spoke with the actor at the LA  premiere of his new film pirates of the  caribbean dead men tell no tales on  Wednesday a Heiner the mighty Spanish  captain with son to be killed thousands  of men no no no men no pirates I rest  you have our entire office obsessed with  your daddy Instagram pic oh thanks I  tried to keep this place out of them but  I'm such I'm so in love with being a dad  I did everything about being a dad um  being a kid again like re-experiencing  life on that level and I have to say you  open my heart in a way I never thought  was possible I just really thought I was  like never gonna open my heart and he  did it is everything they say it is to  have a child change them and you have a  puppy I do I have a mighty man my mighty  man 3 behind Mike well it's a long story  I rescued him from somebody who needed  the you need to rescue him from he's the  best ever and I love him